welcome to our show uh excellent show
tonight we're gonna have a good time yes
yeah we're gonna try that just once and
then go back to the old way uh
okay i'm not sure who saw this uh but
you remember
uh nbc's chris hansen the guy that used
to catch a predator remember that guy
well this is kind of ironic but the guy
known for catching people was arrested
himself
for writing bad checks that's his mug
shot right there
yeah get this while i was reading about
to catch a predator
i found another more upbeat story
remember the cop
who used to dress up like a bush or a
shrub remember that yes
shrub cop yes hide outside he was
camouflaged as a bush or something
and he would nab the predator when they
came out yes if you don't remember
here's a clip
he walks outside and is arrested by that
camouflaged officer
it is so freaking strange see watch it
just one more time
once he gets his clothes back on he
walks outside
and is arrested by that camouflaged
officer
that cop was recently honored at police
headquarters
take a look shrubcop for your years of
service and dedication to the law
enforcement community
we honor you
that's like a happy part of this uh of
the story of this show you know there
was the down part this is the up part
you think it's great right no it's not
because this happened right after the
medal ceremony check it out
shrimp cop was coming out it's gonna be
taken down by
look at this another shrub cop
get on the ground cop was arrested for
bribery
he was on the take the whole time but
the story doesn't end there
apparently shrub cop number two had an
outstanding warrant for money
laundering so here's what happened to
him this is too bad maybe heading out of
here
between five and five thirty if you want
to head on down right now get down
yes dana he got taken down by fence cop
wow
get down yes stay down what the hell so
obviously i had to look into what
happened to fence cop
turns out fence cop got home and then
this happened
down on the ground you're under arrest
down on the ground
exactly fence cop was arrested by
entire house cops yeah
that really happened now
and i want to thank you for sticking
with this bit so far
now i'm really happy to report that this
whole sad saga has a very happy ending
the original shrub cop was released on a
technicality
that's right he's here tonight so let's
give a hand to the
original shrub cop he's here thank you
thank you thank you so this whole story
really does have a happy ending
or does it actually joke's on you
shrubcop
this whole thing was a sting operation
to bust you for credit card fraud
get him boys
please get down you're doing all right
ladies and gentlemen thanks to stair cop
and person in the audience cop
we have arrested shrubcop
take him away boys let's get him out of
here
appreciate the irony of how hard it is
for staircopt to take the stairs
you know i i think if i remember
arrested by stair cop i'm going to try
and make a break